[Musik]
lateinamerika hat diese wunderbare
üppige natur
immense welt das zuhause so vieler
bewohner
wo ein samen in die erde kommt sprießt
die natur dem himmel entgegen
und unter wasser tummelt sich
vielfältiges leben
[Musik]
doch der klimawandel bedroht mensch und
natur
der klimawandel findet bereits statt die
frage ist nicht wann er ist eine
tatsache
die sehnsucht nach wirtschaftlichem
fortschritt ist groß in lateinamerika
in panama wird darum kräftig abgeholzt
trotz klimawandel
landwirte wollen mehr weideland für ihre
rinder könnte ausgerechnet der verkauf
von tropenholz die lösung gegen die
massen rodung sein
machen wir es um geld zu verdienen oder
um die welt zu retten das tolle ist wir
brauchen da gar nicht irgendwie zu
unterscheiden wenn man dass beide vor
jana wurden riesige ölvorkommen gefunden
das arme land hofft auf das große geld
auch wenn sie selbst schon stark unter
dem klimawandel leiden
es regt sich widerstand gegen
steuern in zeiten des klimawandels neue
lösungen finden für wirtschaft und
umwelt
teams aus aller welt wollen in
lateinamerika den beweis antreten
san andrés ist eine kleine
kolumbianische insel inmitten der
karibik sein türkises wasser ist ein
bedeutender touristenmagnet wovon die
insel aber eigentlich lebt sind seine
tauchtouren zum korallenriff
[Musik]
für manche aber bedeutet das revier
arbeiten unter druck
vielmehr ist es ein wettlauf gegen die
zeit für den meeresbiologen fan und
teuer und sein team
seit jahren hat sich der kolumbianer der
rettung der korallenriffe verschrieben
der meeresbiologe bringt gesunde koran
stücke an wo andere abgestorben sind
die korallenriffe der welt sind sehr
bedroht die zeit spielt gegen uns alles
was wir tun können ist wichtig und jeder
muss seinen beitrag leisten ob es kleine
oder große taten sind alles zählt
fahrer muss nach helfen denn das riff
ist krank
fast 30 prozent der korallen der karibik
sterben gerade schleichend warum da ist
zum einen die überfischung es gibt zu
viel abwasser und düngemittel im meer
zum anderen ist da der klimawandel der
erwärmt das meer hurricanes wüten
stärker alles zusammen führt zum
korallen stärken
was wir machen müssen ist in riffen und
den korallen zeit zu geben damit sie
sich anpassen können während wir
versuchen den klima war ihre kontrolle
zu bringen oder zu stoppen können sie
versuchen sich den neuen bedingungen
anzupassen
ebenso einem dress gibt es nun große
hoffnung und die kommt aus europa
hana hat ein deutschschweizer team auf
die karibik insel eingeladen sie wollen
nicht nur riffe restaurieren sie wollen
neue risse erschaffen lange haben sie
auf ihre besondere und sehr empfindliche
fracht gewartet
früher mit anderen sachen anfangen
wollen und alles dafür war aber auch in
diesen boxen sagt niemand rein geschaut
wie viele von den
und so ist die anspannung groß als sich
das team ran macht die kiste zu öffnen
ist alles ganz geblieben
[Musik]
diesen großer erleichterung ist eine
frau
zum vorschein kommen viele
unterschiedliche ton bausteine oder auch
briggs genannt
entworfen in zürich und ins leben
gerufen durch einen 3d drucker
die haben alle verschiedene strukturen
und da können die korallen wachsen genau
zusammen sollen sie ein künstliches riff
werden das erste seiner art
und das besondere anrufen bausteine zum
1 das ist sehr wichtig war dass das
modul ein modulares system das heißt man
kann es mit tauchern leicht bewegen und
unterwasser installieren dann das
material ton es eben recht groß aber
auch für andere
festlegen
fische brauchen korallenriffe als futter
als zu hause und als lästige grünen
nachwuchs korallen brauchen fische die
sie pflegen ein kreislauf der bedroht
ist und das betrifft auch den menschen
denn nur ein gesunder ozean bringt
menschen fisch zum essen und vor allem
sauerstoff zum atmen
damit dass thon riff in san andrés
entstehen kann brauchte es spenden und
es braucht freiwillige helfer so ist ein
internationales team zusammen gekommen
angeführt durch die forscherinnen
es ist ein erfolg wenn wir merken nach
paar monaten und sogar paar jahren dass
es gibt es von korallen also das baby
war in von korallen sich fest und
einzige haben in unserer
das pilotprojekt beginnt was über jahre
vor allem am computer geplant wurde soll
jetzt zum leben erwachen als erstes
braucht es einen beton fundament auf dem
die bausteine festen halt finden sollen
das sind viele stunden arbeit wir werden
hierher zurückkehren
[Musik]
überall in lateinamerika gibt es die
bemühungen den klimawandel mit neuen
ideen die stirn zu bieten auch in panama
es ist noch früh am morgen in las lajas
im südwesten des landes
[Musik]
noch bevor es drückend heiß wird ist
ilja alle menschen auf den beinen um an
ihrem herzensprojekt zu arbeiten sie
züchtet starkes wertvolles tropenholz
[Musik]
es ist der anfang ist der anfang von
allem es ist wunderbar wie aus einer
miniatur wie aus einem so kleinen samen
ein gigant des waldes werden kann
wenn man sie dann wachsen sie denkt man
wow was für ein wunder
ihr garten ist ihr labor jahrzehntelang
hat sie die besten samen der stärksten
truppen bäume gesucht und gezüchtet weil
viele von ihnen in panama schon
verschwunden sind in ihrer kindheit
waren brandrodungen für die
landwirtschaft gang und gäbe für sie war
es ein trauma
die wälder im sommer über monate brennen
zu sehen war furchtbar wertvolle bäume
riesige bäume ohne dass es irgendein
verständnis dafür gab
forstwirtschaft zu studieren war mein
mittel um etwas dagegen zu tun um es
rückgängig zu machen
lilianas mission ist das aufforsten es
ist eine vision die sie mit ihrem
partner teilt im hamburger andreas eckl
und sie wollen nicht einzelne bäume
pflanzen sondern riesige wälder
wenn man nur bäume pflanzt und dann
nicht weiß was dahinter her damit
passiert dann hat man eigentlich noch
gar nichts gemacht einen baum pflanzen
alleine bringt nichts wir brauchen neue
wälder in riesigen ausmaßen auf der welt
70 prozent der waldfläche in panama
wurde bereits gerodet um platz zu
schaffen zum beispiel für rinder
auch robinson trio hat bereits massiv
abgeholzt für den rinderzüchter seine
familie und seine männer steht heute
einiges an arbeit an
[Musik]
seitdem oder bin schon denken kann hat
er mitgeholfen bei der rinderzucht seine
eltern und großeltern
[Musik]
man trägt es im blut
das begeistert mich es macht mich
glücklich wie die kleinen kälber
heranwachsen das ist mein stolz
[Musik]
heute werden die tiere gebrandmarkt und
geimpft
angefangen hat robinson mit vier rindern
nun sind es schon 250 ass bringt ihm ein
gutes einkommen und eine zukunft für
seine kinder und kindeskinder sagt er
robinson will seine zucht weiter
ausbauen also wird er seine wälder
weiter abholzen 50 hektar sollen es sein
dass ausgerechnet industrienationen
dagegen auf schreien kann er nicht
verstehen von etwas muss erleben
vom anschauen der bäume können wir nicht
leben
sie tragen nicht mal früchte der weiter
hinter mir der bringt mir kein geld
nichts
mit den rindern schon wenn ich 15 neue
rinder verkauft verdiene ich 3000 4000
dollar
seien wald erscheint robinson wertlos
andreas und liliana wollen das gegenteil
beweisen einen wald erschaffen und mit
ihm geld verdienen indem sie seinen
tropenholz verkaufen
ein deutsches problem das wir glauben
wenn er geld verdient wird dann ist er
schon böse wer glaubt dadurch dass er
kein tropenholz kauft den den wald zu
schützen den tropenwald zuschuss genau
das gegenteil dadurch dass man natürlich
zertifiziert fsc zertifiziertes
tropenholz kauft kriegt er walten wert
und die leute vor ort werden teufel tun
ihn abzuhaken wenn sie davon leben dass
sie da selektiv holz rausholen
die idee sie haben den generationen wald
gegründet eine genossenschaft mit sitz
in hamburg wer etwas gegen den
klimawandel tun will kann mit einem
anteil 500 quadratmeter aufforsten
kostenpunkt knapp 1400 euro
mit dem geld der investoren kaufen sie
abgeholzt das weideland und samen
schaffen arbeitsplätze
so beginnt das aufforsten der tropen
bäume liliana ist dabei äußerst genau
der moment des einpflanzen es bestimmt
das schicksal des baums er ist wie ein
baby das bei der geburt gute nahrung
braucht sonst verliert er sein potential
cd tropischer eichel mandl mit ihnen und
um sie herum soll ein richtiger
widerstandsfähiger wald entstehen
von tag eins ist das was hier jetzt
wächst ein investment in die umwelt
nach zwölf jahren steht bereits ein
kleiner wald mit unzähligen
tropenhölzern
der umfang ist gut er hat potenzial
zeit für eine erste ausdünnung um
starken bäumen mehr platz zu geben der
investor bekommt jetzt eine erste
rendite bei uns ist es so wir machen
selektive ernte der wald ist immer da
geschlagen einzelne bäume raus der wald
ist immer da und der wald produziert
jedes jahr mehr meerholz und wir nehmen
teil der sonne raus was hat produziert
und verkaufen das machen wir es um geld
zu verdienen oder um die welt zu retten
das tolle ist wir brauchen da gar nicht
irgendwie zu unterscheiden wenn man dass
beide ist
liliana und andreas wollen allerdings
keine truppen holzplantagen sie wollen
dass hier bald für immer und nach knapp
20 jahren haben sie diesen hier schon
erschaffen nicht nur mit massiven edlen
tropenholz sondern mit allem was zu
einem wald gehört
wenn du all das nach 20 jahren arbeit
siehst ist es einfach wunderbar es ist
die motivation zu sagen wir machen
weiter
liliana saat ist aufgegangen
ihre truppen bäume wachsen besonders
schnell
mich begeistert so etwas
die natur dürfte ihr werk tun wo bäume
sind ist wasser kommen tiere zurück
vögel fledermäuse und hasen übernehmen
die arbeit der wiederaufforstung
die tiere essen nur das fruchtfleisch
und übrig bleibt der samen so entsteht
mehr wald die tiere verteilen den samen
ich habe diese bäume hier gar nicht
gepflanzt und doch wachsen sie nun ich
hier
vor 20 jahren war hier nichts und nun
raschelt es in den baumwipfeln
offen
das riesen befriedigung natürlich weil
das zeigt dass es geht wir können das
zurückbauen was wir der natur
weggenommen haben
nach 30 jahren werden sie dann
regelmäßig einzelne tropenhölzer zum
verkauf ausnehmen
während kontinuierlich neue generationen
nachwachsen die genossenschaft hat
mittlerweile 1500 mitglieder aus 18
ländern der wald ist da und er ist
wertvoll das motiviert ihre mitarbeiter
es ihnen nachzumachen
das war für mich sehr wertvoll weil ich
auf meinem land jetzt auch bei der
pflanze und was den klimawandel angeht
ist es doch eine hilfe für den planeten
nicht wahr
[Musik]
nachahmer finden das ist das nächste
wichtige ziel der beiden auch eine
gemeinde der indigenen mbh hat um
unterstützung gebeten zu ihrer kultur
gehört die bemalung doch die bäume der
frucht die sie dafür brauchen gibt es
kaum mehr denn die gemeinde wurde von
der regierung umgesiedelt
es gibt kein holz um unsere
traditionellen häuser zu bauen es gibt
keine medizinischen pflanzen näher
das land auf dem sie jetzt leben wurde
von einer holzfirma gründlich gerodet
elia berät sie wie sie wieder aufforsten
können
wenn wir uns da wiederaufforstung
verschreiben dann hilft das unserer
gemeinde einerseits hilft es uns
wirtschaftlich aber nicht nur die
pflanzen ja nicht nur um sie zu
verkaufen es ist auch für unser
gemeinwohl und die
idee der natur nur das notwendigste zu
entnehmen und so viel wie möglich zu
erhalten sei identisch mit ihrer kultur
wenn sie schon so umtriebig und wissens
hungrig sind wenn es meine botschaft
bleibt am ball bildet euch weiter damit
ihr zu umweltaktivisten werdet zu
helfern des waldes
ob sich auch die landwirte überzeugen
lassen
liliana und andreas nehmen weite wege
und alle unannehmlichkeiten in kauf um
rinderzüchter robinson trio vom roten
abzubringen
ein hektar bringt nach 30 jahren 1000
dollar gewinn jedes jahr und robinson
hat 300 hektar land
du kannst damit in zukunft geld
verdienen und den wert deiner farm
erhöhen
alles hängt vom profit ab wenn das geld
stimmt wäre es das wert vielleicht ist
holzverkauf ja besser als die
rinderzucht
es wäre ein langfristiges investment
aber robinsons töchter und ihre kinder
könnten vom verkauf der tropenhölzer ein
gutes und vor allem nachhaltiges leben
führen
während indianer und andreas fleißig für
nachahmer kämpfen um den klimawandel zu
bremsen machen andere länder das genaue
gegenteil
[Musik]
im südamerikanischen guyana wurde
feinstes rohöl gefunden und das hat eine
diskussion ausgelöst
reichtum oder umweltschutz
wenn die flut beginnt kann das boot
ablegen dann geht es wieder raus aufs
offene meer am meer danisch und ihr
kapitän radi
drei männer die von kindesbeinen an vom
fischfang leben
[Musik]
ich genieße es zur arbeit raus zu fahren
und meine crew zum arbeiten zu bringen
der fischfang gefällt mir fisch bedeutet
für unsere familie alles hilft mir meine
kinder zu ernähren ich bin derjenige der
das geld nach hause bringt
zeit die netze auszuwerfen als sie ins
wasser gleiten bieten sie zum ozean dass
er sie mit fisch segnen soll
drei tage könnte der einsatz dauern so
genau kann man das nicht mehr sagen das
meer bietet ihnen alles um sich in
dieser zeit selbst zu versorgen
das meer ist ihr leben und darum haben
sie die veränderungen der umwelt schnell
bemerkt
es hat sich viel verändert
es ist heißer geworden und der wind
rauer das meer wird wilders
ich weiß nicht ob es an den ölbohrungen
liegt aber es wird immer schwerer fisch
zu fangen
früher brauchten wir nur drei tage um
das boot voll zu bekommen jetzt sind es
sieben tage
irgendwo weiter draußen wird jetzt öl
gefördert gehört haben sie davon gesehen
haben sie es nicht in die nähe der
plattform dürfen sie nicht fahren ihre
größte sorge ist dass durch einen unfall
dort öl ins meer gelangt
wenn das passiert geht die
fischindustrie zugrunde wir können dicht
machen
das wäre hart
irland soll durch das öl bald steinreich
werden hören sie für die fische ist das
alles nicht greifbar sie leben im hier
und jetzt
guyana ist ein sonderling in südamerika
in der ehemaligen britischen kolonie
besteht die größte bevölkerungsgruppe
aus nachfahren von indischen dienstboten
und afrikanischen sklaven
etwa 800.000 menschen leben hier fast
alle an der küste bislang war das land
arm bislang doch jetzt wendet sich das
blatt
denn der us gigant exxon mobil findet
feinstes rohöl im meer vor trojaner seit
2020 fließt das schwarze gold der
minister für natürliche ressourcen
erwartet für die zukunft einen wahren
geldsegen
guyana könnte wenn man es pro kopf sieht
zu einem der reichsten länder der welt
werden sowie katar im augenblick haben
wir geschätzt zehn milliarden barrel öl
und das ist nur in einer region wir
haben noch so viele andere sektoren wo
gerade gesucht wird wir erwarten dass
wir noch sehr viel mehr film
aus der armut zum reichtum wie im
märchen doch der neue schatz kommt in
zeiten des klimawandels
im werbefilm von exxon mobil wird von
der befreiung des artikels gesprochen
nicht aber von seinen konsequenzen für
die umwelt
doch die ölförderung selbst und der
verbrauch später erzeugen treibhausgase
ölreichtum steht gegen umweltschutz und
die regierung entscheidet sich für den
reichtum
wir müssen sichergehen dass wir mit
unseren ressourcen so schnell wie
möglich so viel geld wie möglich
verdienen in vielleicht zwanzig dreißig
jahren wird die nachfrage nach öl nicht
mehr so sein wie heute aber ich denke es
ist nur fair dass wir unsere ressourcen
so nutzen dass wir unser land entwickeln
sowie andere länder ist aufgetan haben
und es auch unsere bürger ein besseres
leben leben können
85 von guyana besteht aus regenwald
damit ist das kleine land so etwas wie
ein co2 staubsauger hilft abzumildern
was große industrienationen anrichten
doch nun wird auch guyana mit dem erdöl
zum klimawandel beitragen das ist nicht
nur für den planeten kritisch sondern
besonders für guyana selbst
denn die küste guyanas liegt unterhalb
des meeresspiegels seit jeher brauchte
stämme um das land zu schützen doch
durch den klimawandel werden die dämme
vom salz wasser überspült und zerstört
die felder der landwirte
alles was du hier siehst sind zerstörte
reisfelder seitdem das hier alles vom
mehr überschwemmt wurde gab es keine
ernte mehr bis heute
wegen der überschwemmung konnte richard
jordan drei jahre kein reis auf seinem
feld an pflanzen rinder und schafe sind
ihm verendet weil futter fehlte
die überschwemmungen mit salzwasser ist
gerade überwunden da geht ihm ein
anderes reisfeld im starkregen unter
für mich als landwirt ist es sehr
frustrierend
du hast auf der einen seite das
meerwasser und auf der anderen den
starkregen zu viel wasser überall
wenn ich ehrlich bin bevorzuge ich den
regen denn das meerwasser lässt nichts
mehr wachsen die tiere können das wasser
auch nicht dringend an es wächst kein
pflänzchen das salzwasser ist ein großes
problem aber eigentlich bist du wieder
das eine noch das andere
[Musik]
an den klimawandel müsse man sich
anpassen denn trotz seiner großen
probleme ist richard für die ölförderung
[Musik]
ich denke wir kommen günstiger an
produkte günstiger als benzin
die produktionskosten würden sinken und
unser gewinn würde steigen ich sehe es
als chance viele länder sind durch öl
reich geworden wenn es richtig verwaltet
wird
durch die ölindustrie sind neue
arbeitsplätze entstanden auf den
plattformen und auch an land
doch was bringt reichtum und profit wenn
es keine lebenswerte umwelt mehr gibt
android home ist mit seinen kindern
spielt wirkt die welt unbeschwert doch
der universitäts dekan und
umweltaktivist sorgt sich sehr um die
zukunft seiner kinder
treue hat die regierung verklagt weil
die bürger laut verfassung das recht auf
eine gesunde umwelt haben das oberste
gericht sollen nun grundsätzlich klären
ob ölförderung und klimaschutz mit der
verfassung vereinbar sind
was werden wir den nachfolgenden
generationen hinterlassen werden wir
alles ausbeuten werden wir die rechnung
dann unseren kindern und kindeskindern
überlassen welche ressourcen werden sie
noch haben
machen wir alles richtig das ist die
über allem stehende frage bei allem was
ich tue ich will sichergehen dass wir
ihnen etwas hinterlassen oder dass wir
es so machen dass es nicht nur schnelles
geld für einige wenige gibt
die regierung sei völlig unerfahren im
ölgeschäft die institutionen schwach das
öl somit leichte beute für unternehmer
politiker und ihre interessensgruppen
diejenigen die im ölgeschäft involviert
sind werden davon profitieren
und wenn der wohlstand nicht jeden von
uns erreicht sollte es kein
wirtschaftsprojekt von uns sein ich
glaube keine sekunde dass das land reich
wird
sein ziel jetzt ist eine
ortsbesichtigung es geht um die
gesundheit die durch die ölindustrie
gefährdet sei der treffpunkt liegt am
rande eines wohngebietes wander und ihre
schwester gar nutzer sind außer sich in
unmittelbarer nähe zu ihren häusern
entsteht eine gefahren müllanlage der
regierung habe die anwohner nicht
informiert und fakten geschaffen die
regierung sogar die umweltbehörde
bejubelt das geschäft mit öl und gas wie
kann eine umweltbehörde wagen das hier
eigenständig durchzuwinken ohne eine
studie zu den umweltauswirkungen wir
bringen die umweltbehörde vor gericht
ich denke dass die regierung in weiten
teilen macht was sie will sie schauen
was das minimum an information ist zudem
sie gesetzlich verpflichtet sind es gibt
keine tiefe wertschätzung der demokratie
oder der ansichten der bürger
unsere filmaufnahmen stören das
sicherheitspersonal
keine 50 meter weiter hinter dem zaun
wohnen die schwestern das ist die
zufahrt zu unserem grundstück
das ist mein land hier wollte ich mein
haus bauen und jetzt kann ich hier
jemals bauen wenn das wir nicht
verschwindet ist es dann noch sicher
hier zu leben oder werden wir alle
umziehen müssen und wenn ja wohin wo ist
ein sicherer platz in guyana um dahin zu
ziehen
schon 2022 wird die ölförderung
verstärkt exxon mobil ist in guyana
bislang der große gewinner hat sich eine
außergewöhnlich hohe gewinnbeteiligung
gesichert ein interview beim unternehmen
bekommen wir nicht
seid ihr legal hier wie heißen sie
zurück bei den fischern fünf tage waren
sie unterwegs auf hoher see es ist der
letzte song auf ihrem rückweg in die
bucht
[Musik]
das ist der beste moment jetzt wenn wir
den fisch rausholen auch wenn wir nicht
die mengen an fisch gefangen haben die
wir uns erhofft
julianna steht vor einer großen
zeitenwende ein reiches land das wäre
schon großartig meinen die fischer doch
bringt das öl ihnen wirklich mehr
wohlstand für sie zählt vor allem dass
sie auch weiterhin ein gesundes mehr
haben von dem sie leben können
auf der kolumbianischen karibikinsel san
andrés steht der zweite tauchgang und
die nächste etappe für das forscherteam
und ihre helfer bevor das turnier wird
aufgebaut
kiste um kiste werden jetzt die ton
bausteine für das ton riff in acht meter
tiefe hinabgelassen
drei jahre haben die meeresbiologin
ulrike und hanna zusammen mit der ton
künstlerin marie die besten formen und
strukturen für ihre bausteine erforscht
und entwickelt damit sich hier fische
und korallen polypen ansiedeln mit dem
ton verwachsen und selbstständig weiter
wachsen na ja wir haben einfach momentan
auf der welt das problem dass bis mitte
des jahrhunderts über 90 prozent aller
korallenriffe nennt werden wenn wir
nichts machen
von der hamburg und entschieden einfach
zügig anzufangen etwas zu machen
und das ist jetzt unser erstes aber wir
denken großen 15 jahren wollen wir
natürlich ganz viele dass wir wieder
aufbauen können und so den ruf etwas
mehr zeit kaufen um auf die neuen
bedingungen reagieren zu können
baustein für baustein gelingt der aufbau
alle elemente fügen sich problemlos
ineinander ein das ist nicht
selbstverständlich
was über jahre in zürich geplant wurde
wird realität auf dem karibischen
meeresboden
[Musik]
also das war ein traum von uns haben das
alles überlegt alles geplant und jetzt
ist endlich mal da
bei aller freude auch wenn das projekt
funktioniert wenn sich tatsächlich
korallen am ton riff ansiedeln löst das
nicht das problem des klimawandels
wir müssen auf jeden fall die nächsten
30 40 jahre klimawandel unter kontrolle
bekommen sonst es all das was die ganze
community macht am koran
wissenschaftlern und kastration menschen
eigentlich umsonst
am abend schuld der meeresbiologe verlor
das team für den letzten arbeitsschritt
dennoch fehlt morgen sollen an das tor
allen fragmente angebracht werden um die
natur noch ein klein wenig nachzuhelfen
mit der micro fragmentierung können wir
mittlerweile 25 30 karibische
korallenarten verwenden
das ermöglicht uns dass wir wirklich
riffe restaurieren und nicht nur
einzelne wenige korallenarten verbreiten
der natur nachhelfen das ist schon lange
ein ziel in costa rica
30 prozent des territoriums stehen
bereits unter schutz hier will man ein
neues zeichen setzen gegen den
klimawandel
und das ist es safer heißt das
frachtschiff aus holz es ist weitgehend
klimaneutral gebaut und soll später ohne
jede verschmutzung durch die meere
siegeln
wer die werft asteroide besuchen will
muss erst einmal hoch hinaus ins
baumhaus
hier läuft die korrespondenz mit der
welt hier wird geplant und alles
bürokratische erledigt es ist die
schaltstelle von visionären wie daniel
dort aus kanada mitbegründerin der firma
cell cargo mit einem ambitionierten ziel
a
machine ist unsere mission ist den wert
einer sauberen schifffahrt darzustellen
wir wollen mit das selber unserem
flaggschiff zeigen dass klimafreundliche
frachtschifffahrt funktioniert
finanziell für die umwelt und auch unter
sozialen aspekten
90 prozent des globalen warenverkehrs
erfolgt mit frachtschiffen die mit
schweröl betrieben werden erklärt links
aus kanada aus ihren schornstein wird
ein erheblicher teil der weltweiten
kohlendioxid- und feinstaub emissionen
geblasen selber soll den kurs ändern
beim bau benutzen wir nur nachhaltige
materialien aus der region alles kommt
von hier
wir bauen ein klimafreundliches
handelsunternehmen auf gleichzeitig
setzen wir auch auf nachhaltigen
schiffsbau
ein holzschiff das im vergleich zu stahl
sehr viel umweltfreundlicher ist wenn es
richtig gemacht wird
das 45 meter lange schiff soll ab 2022
nur mit windkraft und wenn nötig mit
unterstützung von solarbetriebenen
elektromotoren waren transportieren
dafür wird hier gehämmert und gehobelt
dutzende frauen und männer aus costa
rica und der ganzen welt haben sich von
der idee anstecken lassen zur vision vom
set cargo gehört auch anwohner des
dorfes an bord zu holen via mail at
so eine arbeit hätte ich mir nie
vorstellen können bei der ich sogar dazu
lernen kann ich liebe es zuerst habe ich
am großen schiff gearbeitet jetzt an
kleinen beiboot und das wird sehr schön
[Musik]
die werft bietet jobs und perspektiven
das begeisterte arbeiter wie logan
mccanns aus costa rica
das leben hier ist toll jeder tag macht
spaß wenn man sieht wie das schiff
größer und größer wird dann wird man
demütig das inspiriert
auch wenn man den fortschritt in den
sozialen medien verfolgt dann sieht das
aus wie ein traum und ich lebe ihn
schluss mit dem café ran ans werk die
selber wird finanziert durch investments
auch von privatpersonen und
kleinanlegern die das
nachhaltigkeitsprojekte überzeugt logan
und die ganze mannschaft sind besessen
von der idee des saubersten transport
schiffes der welt
ein holzschiff hält bis zu 150 jahre
natürlich wird es im laufe der jahre
nach vielen pazifik überquerungen hier
und da mal eine reparatur geben
müssen planken ausgetauscht werden
aber selber wird immer weiter fahren
während die großen stahl schiffe die so
große auswirkungen auf die umwelt haben
oft schon nach 15 20 jahren irgendwo in
drittweltländern angelandet und
ausgeschlachtet werden
brauchen wir wirklich nicht
nachhaltigkeit wird hier bis ins
kleinste detail gelebt so gehört zum
werftgelände auch der eigene organische
anbau von gemüse und früchten was
anmutet wie ein hippie dorf ist
tatsächlich ein konsequentes
strategisches business unternehmen mit
grünen mitteln
hier ist sozusagen unsere baumschule wir
haben hier eine regel von allem was wir
essen nehmen wir die samen und pflanzen
sie wieder ein
was hier wächst wandert nur wenige meter
weiter in die kantine
[Musik]
das essen ist immer reichlich meistens
vegetarisch die köchin sind alle aus dem
dorf bunter morales auch sie haben hier
neue arbeit gefunden
während sich die einen stärken ist
managerin danielle unterwegs zu einem
potentiellen kunden wissen ware sie
gerne mit ihrem segel frachter
transportieren wollen
es geht um eine kleine öko
kaffeeplantage auch sie alle hier sind
idealisten die unter tropischen
bedingungen mitten im regenwald schuften
viele schauer große hitze aber jede
menge zuversicht dass sich all das lohnt
sie wollen den markt in den usa und in
kanada erobern den der feinschmecker und
umweltbewussten das passt doch zur
selber
kleine produzenten oder solche die
organisch anbauen so wie diese farben
die passen genau in unser business
konzept was wir natürlich am liebsten
laden wollen sind eben solche güter mit
solchen geschichten dahinter
seit mehr als zehn jahren sucht nur am
bereits das richtige konzept um ohne
einsatz von chemie und pestiziden einen
der besten kaffees anzupflanzen
immer wieder gab es rückschläge pflanzen
die kaputt gingen oder zu wenig ertrag
brachten jetzt aber sehen sie sich auf
dem richtigen weg
mein ziel ist in nordamerika abnehmer zu
finden und die bohnen dann mit der
selber dorthin zu transportieren
es ist ein persönliches produkt der
kunde weiß woher es kommt und er weiß
dass die ware klimafreundlich zum
zielort gelangt in den usa oder kanada
mit der gewissheit dass der kaffee nicht
mit anderen gütern vermischt wird
zurück bei der sail gerade setzt logen
die erste diele für das hauptdeck nach
zwei jahren arbeit fast alles in
handarbeit
es gibt keine kräne und keiner anderen
großmaschinen
verlogen und die kollegen entsteht so
eine noch intensivere beziehung zu ihrem
schiff und auch weil jeder von ihnen
einen kleinen besitzanteil am schiff
bekommt
der gedanke daran hilft natürlich auch
zu verstehen dass das nicht nur für
irgendeine firma mache ich tue das für
die welt und auch für mich ich kann es
kaum abwarten bis zum stapellauf es wird
magisch und wird mit sicherheit ein
langer tag aber es wird ein guter tag
mag sein dass handarbeit seine zeit
braucht meint links aber die
schifffahrtsindustrie sei viel zu
langsam im umweltschutz erst bis 2050
wollen die lira treibhausgase auf den
meeren halbieren
mein ziel ist nur dieses boot ins wasser
zu bekommen so einfach ist das wir
können hier ein glückliches produktives
leben führen unsere talente ausspielen
das machen was uns wichtig ist und das
ganze auf nachhaltige weise
jeden tag um 16 uhr fällt für gillette
der hammer feierabend nur noch klar
schiff machen bevor der heimweg beginnt
ich gehe nicht müde und völlig geschafft
nach hause das was wir tun das natürlich
kompliziert aber es ermüdet nicht es ist
toll
die alleinerziehende mutter ist mächtig
stolz dass sie auf der werft arbeiten
kann denn ihr dorf bunter morales liegt
in einer der ärmsten regionen costa
ricas jobs sind mangelware
jetzt hat sie geregelte arbeitszeiten
und eine gute bezahlung als putzkraft
hat sie bei den schiffsbauern angefangen
und sich dann weitergebildet zur
schreinerin
davor lebte kabinett davon an der küste
zwischen den mangroven fische zu fangen
gottseidank gehöre ich nun zum team der
selber und muss nicht mehr durch die
mangroven laufen das war früher die
einzige möglichkeit etwas zu verdienen
irgendwie musste ich mit meiner tochter
überleben
zurück im baumhaus arbeitet daniel nicht
nur an der selber das team ist auch
politisch aktiv appelliert an
organisationen und regierungen die
emissionen der schifffahrt
runterzubringen
ich möchte nicht wie eine träumerin
klingen aber ja ich glaube dass unsere
bemühungen hier bereits die welt
verändern wir waren schon eingeladen bei
der klimakonferenz in bonn viele
großunternehmen beachten unsere arbeit
auch die vereinten nationen
[Applaus]
selber wird nur ein kleines frachtschiff
im vergleich zu den stahlriesen auf den
ozean aber ihren erbauern geht es auch
nicht um den maximalen wirtschaftlichen
profit es geht um eine änderung des
kurses in zeiten des klimawandels
[Musik]
zurück auf der karibikinsel san andrés
beginnt der letzte tag des projektes
riff aufbau
fahrer hat über jahre besonders
widerstandsfähige korallen gezüchtet und
die werden nun in winzige teile
geschnitten
zu das zurück ins wasser jetzt musst du
stücke von einem zentimeter
jeder der freiwilligen helfer ist
geschult und darf mit anpacken
machen statt auf hilfe warten ist
ohnehin das motto aller her
das problem der riss geht uns alle an
und wir brauchen alle wir können nicht
auf die finanzierung der regierung oder
internationale hilfe warten sie alle
sind hier zum tauchen gekommen aber sie
machen nicht nur über blasen sie haben
ein ziel sie tauchen mit einem vorsatz
um die ansiedlung der korallen am griff
zu beschleunigen heftet das team die
korallen fragmente an die turm bausteine
weil sie leben werden sie hier weiter
wachsen wenn das gelingt soll das
projekt so richtig losgehen also das
sind jetzt so etwa vier meter lang drei
meter breit gewesen
wir wollen nächstes jahr 20 meter erst
mal probieren und dann einen 3 45 jahren
kilometerweise das ist viel mehr werden
drei tage dauerte der aufbau ihres tores
ab jetzt muss die natur ihr werk über
jahre selbst tun
der erste fisch schon vorbei eine erste
hausbesichtigung
für das internationale team war der
einsatz jetzt schon ein erfolg weil sie
alles gegeben haben um dem klimawandel
die stirn zu bieten
[Musik]